well get ready for a frozen reunion
Kristen Bell and Josh GAD that's on an
Olaf to your kids of course aren't
together again for Josh's new animated
TV series and how about this it has
already gotten the seal of approval from
Kristen's husband Dax Shepard my husband
who hates everything and hate especially
cartoons and musicals the within the
first 20 minutes he looks at me he goes
wow you you guys have something really
special on your hands
where else can your son and daughters me
signing onto this project went a little
bit like this mmm hello hey Kristin its
Josh do you wanna do a cartoon with me
sure
okay bye - a person's all of our first
choices said yes Central's large
debuting tomorrow on Apple TV plus it's
a reunion of sorts of course there's the
frozen connection Josh was college
classmates with Leslie Odom Jr who
wanted Tony alongside to be Diggs for
Hamilton who guest starred on Titus
Burgess to show the unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt Kristin and Kathryn Hahn worked
together on dad mom's they think all
moms will appreciate the animated comedy
slash musical there's like a sweet
kindness and a dear message in the
middle of it which is the importance of
family it's an adult cartoon but it's
totally kids safe so it's co-viewing for
sure
Josh's Beauty and the Beast co-star
Stanley Tucci voices an elderly business
woman who plans to destroy Central Park
there isn't anything Stan Lee can't do
and make look cool yeah kind of like his
mesmerizing cocktail instructionals on
Instagram I was a bartender many years
ago when I was young they still stay
with you that's good some celebrities
hit Jeff for like a virtual happy hour
kind of thing okay awful Ryan Reynolds
hello he's the worst nerd
[Music]